let's be honest you don't really need to
watch every movie in every popular
franchise do you for one reason or
another some movies just aren't worth
the trouble these are the popcorn flick
switch franchise fans are better off
skipping the lost world Jurassic Park
isn't exactly a bad movie but it is a
little too long and tends to feel like a
bad rehashing of their biggest hit aside
from a few stellar action sequences the
movie doesn't really move the Jurassic
Park saga forward and the ostensible
payoff of a t-rex running roughshod over
San Diego only occupies the final twenty
or thirty minutes of the film and yes a
case could be made for Jurassic Park 3
being in essential viewing - but at 90
minutes that installment is a simple
dopey monster movie that doesn't ever
wear out it's welcome and as the
Jurassic films continue to strip-mine
the tired man must not tinker with
nature trope it's worth remembering that
in the end they're all dopey monster
movies at heart it's kind of a shame
that x-men The Last Stand is so very
mediocre and skippable because the end
of x2 suggested a powerful transition to
Marvel's classic Dark Phoenix storyline
with its own homage to Star Trek - the
Wrath of Khan
instead the third film in the original
x-men trilogy waters down Jean Grey
story by crowding the movie with an
endless array of unnecessary villains
including a vast collection of old and
new bad guys from the Brotherhood of
Evil Mutants with 2011's x-men first
class screenwriters Matt Vaughn and Jane
Goldman managed the tricky feat of
creating a film that was both a prequel
and reboot of the x-men franchise its
sequel x-men Days of Future past
adapted a classic Marvel Comics
storyline which unceremoniously retcon
the events of the last stand out of
existence miss this movie and you won't
miss much at all the alien movies are
renowned for their ability to purvey an
overwhelming inevitable and deeply
uncomfortable sense of dread whether
it's just ripley in that single
xenomorph in the original film or the
most recent cast of colonial characters
introduced in 2017 s alien covenant it's
usually a certainty that there will be
plenty of jump-scares grizzly chess
bursters galore and lots and lots of
Prometheus fails on a number of levels
but it's that lack of any real dread
that really makes it the most skippable
of alien movies modern franchises may
love to fill their universes with
obscure and often unnecessary origin
stories and that may work for running up
box office numbers but it doesn't make
the movies themselves any more
interesting filled with backstory yet
unable to strike that sense of fear
which makes alien movies so great
Prometheus just ends up feeling bloated
if you're a star Wars fan you're likely
familiar with the machete order a
viewing plan devised by rod Hilton in
which the prequels slot into the
original trilogy right after the Empire
Strikes Back
instead of attacked on afterthought the
prequels suddenly become a long
flashback sequence with far greater
emotional resonance than they originally
had notably the machete order amidst the
Phantom Menace the movie doesn't really
contain any critical story points
relevant to the rise and fall of Anakin
Skywalker or his eventual Redemption so
out it goes whatever order you do watch
these films in it's very easy to omit
the first Star Wars prequel without
missing any important story at all of
course it doesn't help that the Phantom
Menace is also a completely horrible
movie chances are it's not only as bad
as you remember it it's actually worse
just skip it Terminator Genisys was
envisioned as a fresh start for the
Terminator franchise arriving six years
after 2009's Terminator Salvation which
is today probably best remembered morph
of Christian Bale's on set rants than
for the movie itself Thor the dark world
Alan Taylor stepped up to direct joined
by Game of Thrones star Emilia Clarke
alongside Arnold Schwarzenegger himself
after the project registered a
disappointing box-office return mostly
because it opened in competition with
Jurassic world sequel plans were put on
hold and work started on yet another
soft reboot which picks up the plot
after 1991 s Terminator 2 Judgment Day
as it stands Genesis might as well have
never happened
I'll be back what
2008 The Incredible Hulk isn't a
terrible movie it's just that this early
attempt at franchise building came along
before Marvel Studios had figured out
the formula for making their movies
truly great coming mere months after
Ironman The Incredible Hulk wasn't able
to take on any of Jon Favreau's tonal
cues and suffered from the need to
escape the long shadow of angley's
disappointing 2003 Hulk movie Incredible
Hulk does have some interesting
franchise wide backstory involving the
Super Soldier program that gave birth to
Captain America as well as a fun final
scene involving Tony Stark hinting at
the creation of the Avengers but
considering that Mark Ruffalo would
Abele take on the mantle of the green
Goliath from Avengers onward and
considering the current Marvel franchise
marathon clocks in at well over 36 hours
you shouldn't feel too bad for wanting
to give this one a Miss check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]